I believe sales isn't magical because
you built it all from things that you
enjoy put it together it's like building
a house only you get to heat this house
[Music]
yo I'm Jermaine Fowler and I'm about to
teach you how to make a sandwich with
all ingredients from my personal farm
the guy's brisket
we got lettuce limes put the lime in
distinguish this loaf of bread and we
got a Swiss cheese from this cow I
raised myself
her name's fancy fancy the cow and it's
now as I made at home I don't really
teach people how to make sandwiches it's
a secret recipe but I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you how to do it with my guidance
you can you can make sandwiches at home
just as good as mine we're gonna go with
the bread first
I don't like ends of Brits so I'm gonna
leave these out I'm gonna go with the
middle part of the bring it boom
oh yeah that's the pastor that's the
part of the bread you want is the middle
part like how fluffy and wiggly it is
raised his letters from scratch I
remember when it was just a baby little
baby Lance
and I was being ripped apart and put
into some bread this is what lettuce is
made for so I feel bad all you let his
activist stuff they're not gonna use any
limes at all one of my assistants put
him there and I've told them I didn't
want any lon but he didn't anyway so
his ass is fired probably some broccoli
in there I like broccoli you know I've
got to get your vegetables and you a
fiber diet it's important to proof
support the pool got pool without poop
and what's like you know the cheese yeah
there's some cheese in there
yeah Swiss cheese has holes so you can
see what you eat the viewfinders you
know I like to you know I know this
camera up here can see if you cannot see
it your sandwich from the hole that
you're trying to make then it's gonna be
a good sandwich so BAM boom boom boom
boom boom boom there we go oh these two
pieces of brisket this was a made from
the same cow from this cheese poor cow
also you want to get the Middle's of
brisket too just like bred cows don't
want you to know this but their flavour
comes from the middle and there's BBQ
sauce here I don't think I'm gonna use
the barbecue sauce let's give it a taste
I might change my mind
this comes my own recipe to barbecue
sauce
it's actually really good I'm gonna
ladder this [ __ ] with some
barbecue sauce actually doesn't good
barbecue sauce I'm not surprised though
because I made it you know what's weird
am I missing anything let's see we got
the lettuce we got the brisket the
cheese broccoli butter don't think I
need the butter yet but then on top of
there you want to mush it real good that
way you get all the flavors in one area
there you go and then you want to look
at it for about five seconds before you
uh before you cook it all right cool now
you're ready to cook I forgot that the
butter
I know triumph bears me in front of my
viewers I want to add butter to the
grill so it'll burn the sandwich mmm
this butter is also from the same town I
got the brisket from I'm gonna make sure
it's sizzles yeah you can just smell
them the goodness coming from this grill
[Music]
sandwiches ready guys I got a plate so
crispy on the edges I was in the
sandwich is my count fancy uh it's where
I used to sing together know at night
she'd move it I sing r.kelly songs and
stuff it's just one of those things she
would have wanted me to eat her you know
if you fancy
Holly we need the bread cutout surprise
it's not surprise you know
I cook all downtown I'll call this
sandwich the maniac because my name is
Jermaine my dad used to call me Germania
oh you know one more bite one more I
made this [ __ ] those [ __ ] my work I
raised that cow for 12 years okay Bruce
[Music]